هل كنت تعرف الزرقاوي شخصيا لا شخصيا ما
في بيني وبينه علاقه السن ولا الانخراط في
عمل اسلامي يعني هو شخص عادي
ونهج هذا النهج واعجب بهذا النهج وصار فيه
فقط لما سجن على خلفيه الانتظام
المقدسي كتنظيم ارهابي في نظر الدوله
اهله اتصلوا بي حتى افرج عنه وتعاهد بذلك
فبعث الرساله مع شخص انه لا تتدخل لا
تتدخل الطالب
بمصعب الزرقاء
وانه لا يستعين بظالم على ظالم
كان يعتبرك ظالم لا تعمل مع دوله يكفرون
اعضاء مجلس النواب اعضاء الحكومه
في السجن انا كنت رئيس لجنه الحريات وكنت
بمشي في مشروع عفو عام اخذنا موافقه الملك
عليه
وبدانا نحصل الاسماء فتم الافراج عن 600
شخص يعني ايامها فكنت ازورهم ودخلت كان
لقيت شبيلات في السجن وكان جماعات الافغان
في السجن وحزب التحرير وكانوا هؤلاء كلهم
استقبلوني ما عدا هؤلاء التكفيريون لما
وصلت عند الباب اغلق الباب رفضوا اغلقوا
الباب فانا قلت يعني فوق سجنهم ما اكون
دمي ثقيل اذا ما بده يستقبلني انا كمان
كرامه فرجعت اذا همم المقدسي وابو مصعب
الزرقاوي رفضا رؤيتك نعم فهم رفضوه فانا
مشيت مشيت خطوات وكان معي مدير السجن
والامن والقائي بعد قليل خرج واحد من
الغرفه ولا التزم بلباس السجن كانوا
يراعوهم بالبس اللي لابس ثوب قصير
وحامل معه ورقه ودونا ان يسلم علي فقال
انت فلان باللغه الفصيحه فقلت نعم انا
فلان يا عبد الله
فقال هذه من الامير
ورقه مرابطها بخير فاخذتها على طريقه
الملوك القدماء اخذتها
فبمزح مع مدير السجن باقول له انتم امراه
محبوسين قال لي لا قرابتك هذا صار امير
انتخبوا من يومين ههه
زرقاء وصار امير على السبعه اللي موجودين
جوه
وهي موجوده عند الرساله انه انتم تزوروا
دين الله وتعترفوا بالطاغوت وانتم كفار
وانتم وانتم وانتم
يعني
فانا اخذت الورقه فقال لي المدير الامن
الوقائي في السجن قال لي احنا اخذنا نسخه
منها طلب نوصلها اخذناها بس ما بدينالك يا
هلا لان فيها مسبات
لكن اياك انت اخذتها احنا مستحينا نودي لك
اياها قلت لها عليك يعني ما في مشكله هذا
كل الامر
استماره بعض الشباب الاردني
للاسف همم حصل هذا في السجن احيانا السجين
ما بيحلق لحيته لكم متعود يحلق فبتطول
لحيته بيفكروا انه هذا ايش اسلامي صار
وبعضهم يصير يصلي فبيروحوا يحطوهم معهم
يجب عزل هؤلاء لانه مثل المرض هذا
حكى لي احد لاني تعاونت مع اداره السجون
مره في محاورات التكفيريين جلست شهر كامل
في رمضان
يسمعهم واحد واحد وبفضل الله اكثر من 90%
يعني واحد قال لي قال لي انا دخلت على
قضيه قتل بس ان تدين وحطوني مع المقدسي
والمقدسي فهمني وانا ما عندي ارد عليه
فانت بدي ترد عليه رديت عليه وانا فيما
بعد لما خرجت همم
لاحقا في منشورات في كتاب اسمه الرد السوي
على قوي المقدسي فال الشاب كان عنده
تساؤلات كثيره وانا صح مدير السجن قلت له
ما بصير تخلطوهم ما يعني زي المريض واحد
مريض وواحد صحيح بعدين ففي عدوى فكريه
فالشاب اهتدى يعني همم طبعا لا ادري عنه
شيء يعني لانه اتصل علي بعد العيد وقال
مدير السجن الفلاني يريدك فذهبت ظنيت بده
مساعده او شيء فقال لا اضل عندي سؤال يعني
جواب فسال
صرفت يعني
السؤال عن يعني انه طيب همم يعني لا
يحكمون بالاسلام فكيف نقول انه مسلمون قلت
الحكم بالاسلام نسبي فهم يحكمون بالاحوال
الشخصيه وهم يحكمون في قانون البحار
ويحكمون في القانون الدبلوماسي الشريعه
تركت اشياء مساحات واسعه للاجتهاد البشري
المخالفه اللي موجوده في كل الدول العربيه
في قانون الجنايات وفي قانون اقتصاد اللي
هو اباحه الرب وفي قانون الجنايات انه لا
نطبق الحدود الشرعيه باقي ما تبقى يعني
قانون البلديات ايش في شريعه رئيس البلديه
وصفاته عمره وقديش مدته قانون البحار
قانون الجوازات السفر قانون الجنسيه كلها
قوانين اجتهاديه فاكثر من 90% من القوانين
اجتهادات تصلح الجزء البسيط اذا كان واحد
عنده مخالفه 10% بطلعه من الاسلام ثم في
الاسلام ما دام واحد بيكون اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وان محمد رسول الله غصبا عن ابوه
بدي اقول عنه مسلم حتى لو كان تارك
الفرائض هو مسلم
وحسابه عند ربه لانه وقرروا على تركه
الفرائض ولكن لا نكثر